es war noch vor den wahlen
die blochers genießen eine arie aus lack
vorgetragen von ihrem lieblings sängern
während draußen seine partei die messer
wetzt frönt der patron der hehren musik
und eröffnet dem volk seine umfassende
kunstsammlung
eingeladen waren alle die die von
blocher profitiert haben die einen
politisch die anderen weil sie ihm die
millionenschweren bilder verkauft hatten
vernissage oder wahlkampf in
kunstkreisen hielt man sich bedeckt ob
die hohe kunst mit den niederungen der
politik zu tun hat es ist ein ausdruck
kommen sammler gefreut hat der schweizer
kunst politische dimension ich jetzt da
ihnen eigentliche cani der milliardär
jedenfalls ließ es sich nicht nehmen in
ankara manier zu posieren
die atmosphäre war geprägt von den stars
der ausstellung rodler und anker blocher
kauft seine bilder nach einer einfachen
formel bauern von anker berge von rudel
schweizer kunst meist aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert
samtliche schöne bilder es gibt auf der
welt wo sämtliche künstler sondern ich
tue mich auf das konzentrieren würde
politik ist also ich hätte nichts mit
dem politische thema es gibt aber wenn
sie mich fragen was macht eigentlich
stärker oder schwyz
das macht es so wie er politisiert
sammelt er auch kunst
er besetzt die mythen der
traditionsbewussten schweiz die
rechtschaffene landbevölkerung bei anka
überhöht bis zur blonden vollkommenheit
oder bei hudler die berge und
landschaften unbefleckt und schon immer
da gewesen dass ich aus symbol wurde
welche modernen nachhaltigkeit wurde tun
haft bleibt
foto vor dem beliebte vorbild klar dass
du in die interessierte blogger umgibt
sich mit dieser kunst die ewigkeit
verspricht im filmporträt des regisseurs
jean stéphane bron sind seine bilder im
haus allgegenwärtig
ein mann lebt inmitten von werten die
über ihn hinaus weisen zurück bis sie
setzen mein sohn an chemisch die handys
wunderman auf dem sie stehen total
bitter mit der kunst möglichst uhr
locher nutzt seine teuren lieblinge auch
gerne mal für realpolitische argumente
ankers gemeindeschreiber wird für ihn zu
einem rechtschaffenen bauern der in der
bürokratie des staates untergeht
natürlich dass bürokratie gefährlich ist
wenn sie sei nach rees übertrug luther
und die reben mit dem parlamentarier als
mahnmal nasa
es sind die slogans der svp die aus
ankers bildern ein politisches statement
machen
der politiker blocher schafft es mit
seiner kunstsammlung ein visuelles erbe
der schweiz ins rechte lager zu ziehen
wahlkampf ist das eine eine solche
ausstellung zur gleichen zeit das andere
sie wird zum auftakt der nächsten vier
jahre
passend zur politischen stimmung im land